hello there i'm matt abrahams to keep up
with the learning this summer we're
diving back into some of our most
popular episodes think of this as summer
school
as part of our summer learning series
we'll be reintroducing an episode and
pairing it with an assignment for you to
complete fasten your seat belts and
sharpen your pencils
the bottom line matt is giving birth
having sex and laughing with colleagues
in zoom meetings are actually have a lot
in common um we're building trust and no
one's wearing pants oh there you go
well we might not all still be on zoom
anymore but these principles still apply
to humor in the workplace i'm matt
abrahams and i teach strategic
communication at stanford graduate
school of business welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast our episode about
humor came out two years ago and has
been listened to hundreds of thousands
of times by people all over the world
today we want to replay that episode
with a special homework assignment this
is part of our summer learning series
where we take some of our best of
highlight the learnings and make
assignments based on the research today
i'm joined in the studio here with jenny
luna our executive producer at think
fast talk smart
matt this humor episode is still one of
my favorites we recorded it two years
ago and since then jen and naomi have
reached millions with their research on
humor they shared it on ted npr and
they've been on multiple podcasts like
10 happier with dan harris it's been
awesome to see their success
one of my favorite things about this
episode besides how much we all laugh
together is how naomi and jennifer draw
parallels between being funny
and being a good storyteller yeah at its
core comedy really is good storytelling
as you and so many guests have
reiterated on the show storytelling
grabs attention it helps us retain
information and it breeds connection
with others while the business school
might still be on summer break we still
want to give some homework to our
listeners it's a way we can learn from
each other and share resources as a
community jenny tell us about this first
assignment okay i'm excited because i've
been trying this as well jennifer ocher
has a great method on how we can be
funnier in our everyday lives you'll
hear this in the episode but i'm going
to repeat it here write down one
observation per day of an incongruity
something odd something off just
something that you noticed jot it down
in a notebook or on your phone
then at the end of the week look at your
seven observations try to turn one of
those observations into comedy and now
of course we want to hear from you our
listeners share one of those
observations with us on our linkedin
page and don't worry about being
hilarious we are just getting started
and we listen to this episode for tips
on how humor can be your secret weapon
in communication
jennifer ocker is the general atlantic
professor and is a professor of
marketing at stanford gsb she is a
leading expert on how purpose shapes
individuals choices naomi bagdonis
trained at the upright citizens brigade
and teaches courses on humor at the gsb
and the san francisco county jail
in this episode the duo had just
published their awesome book humor
seriously here's our conversation from
thank you jennifer and naomi for being
here
thank you for having us yeah we're
thrilled to be here awesome so first off
congrats on your book i've really
enjoyed reading it and i learned a lot
and i have never laughed out loud while
reading a business book before so thanks
for that
i'm curious
what got you both interested in studying
humor in the first place
for me it started as a personal passion
so i've always loved comedy and found
humor and improv in particular to be a
really important part of my life
but it wasn't until my early 20s that i
had this aha moment at work and it was
not a good one
so i was working at a large consulting
firm and i had a client named bonnie who
i had been working with for a while now
and she knew me pretty well
it was a friday afternoon and we were
getting off the phone as she said to me
naomi i bet i know exactly what you do
on friday nights
a weird a weird thing certainly yeah but
i went along with it
and sh and i said great bonnie what do i
do and she said i bet that you
watch history channel documentaries
while re-ironing your blouses for next
week
re-ironing and she was serious and she
went on to describe this drab apartment
with gray landscape paintings and a cat
which she guessed was named cat oh no
yes oh yes
and uh and it was this real uh this
realization for me that i had been
leading a double life that you know by
night and weekend i was in comedy clubs
in la and i had so much joy and
personality frankly
and at work my persona was really
serious
really polished
um i was good at my job but i had no
semblance of joy or personality
so what happened for me then was i made
it a point to
bring more humor into work and as i did
i found that
it could actually be a powerful tool so
not only could i have more joy in the
office and feel more authentic but it
could actually be a powerful asset for
me
in the professional world just like it
was for me personally
wow that's quite an epiphany and it begs
one question do you have a cat named cat
i do not have a cat named cat although i
have toyed with that being a pretty
clever thing to name a cat but then i
decided it would uh have a short shelf
life so i've
come around to not liking the name cat
as a cat name even though i don't have a
cat i see i see and jennifer tell us how
you got interested in humor
so meanwhile for me humor was really
never a focus
so yeah i mean i like to laugh
which is impossible to say without
sounding like a sociopath yeah but i was
always more more interested in research
in writing getting done
most all of my life has been really
focused on falling in love and finding
ideas
testing hypotheses gathering large data
sets to test those hypotheses
and over the course of time publishing
papers that would document these
scientific findings there's nothing
really in that process that lends itself
to humor or
for me to understand that humor could be
powerful toward toward my goals
but everything really changed for me in
2010 i wrote a book with my husband andy
smith called the dragonfly effect
and it was about the power of story and
networks to drive positive change in the
world
and what ended up happening over the
course of a year
is we ended up working with families who
needed to find
matches in the bone marrow registry or
find matches outside of the registry
in order to hopefully save the life of a
child or a parent or a friend
and in that process of of helping trying
to get over 100 000 people in the bone
marrow bone marrow registry and putting
the model
to work we were able to meet a person
named amit gupta
who had leukemia
and
had such irreverence and such humor and
used such levity with his friends and
his family that
seeing him get people in the bone marrow
industry
and fighting this deadly disease and
persisting and rallying and ultimately
surviving it
i realized how
how much the power of humor and levity
could play
in
in things that were so serious in ways
that i had never imagined before
that's you both of you coming to the
same topic in very different ways i
think is really curious and cool and the
result in your book and the ideas you
have i i think is is fantastic so thank
you for sharing that
you know humor might be more important
today than ever
what can business leaders and managers
do in this current environment where
everyone is stressed out working
remotely interacting through screens
what can they do to implement or make it
known that there is still a place for
humor in the workplace
well
good question matt um thank you you know
i think you're welcome um one of the
things that um we found is that there's
these myths or misperceptions about
humor for example with me you know i
just i really had this misperception
that humor was not only
um not serious not important but it
would actually serve to distract
um and we find that again and again when
we ask people what holds them back from
using humor at work
many believe that humor simply has no
place amidst serious work
um we're worried about harming our
credibility and not necessarily take
being taken seriously
and yet in studies large-scale studies
that we've run and that others have run
the large majority of leaders really
prefer employees with a sense of humor
and believe that employees with a sense
of humor do better work
um and not and not just that but
but it affects the way people interact
with you
showing your sense of humor can make our
peers and our friends attribute even
more
um perceptions of confidence competence
and even status to us and vote us into
leadership roles
um while also cultivating a sense of
trust
wow humor really does provide lots of uh
benefits
yeah you know and that last point about
trust is
more crucial now than ever we're finding
um you know the fact that humor is a
powerful tool to build trust especially
when you consider two things so first
matt you mentioned this shift remote
remote work right yes living in a
different world and it's simply harder
to peel away some of those superficial
layers and feel comfortable enough to
share with each other authentically
um and then and then second a growing
body of research shows that our
businesses are facing a crisis of trust
um one
uh 2019 hbr survey found that 58 of
employees trust a complete stranger more
than their own boss oh wow
so you know we're finding that the
expectations of today's leaders um are
shifting
uh that's exactly right i mean think
about it it used to be that leaders
needed to be revered
and now they need to be understood
and all the while you know humor is
particularly potent alexa for for trust
and when we laugh with someone be it in
person or even over screens through zoom
uh naomi connor and i are teaching a
class right now and it is remarkable how
much
we laugh with our students even through
screens
what happens is our brains release the
hormone oxytocin and we're essentially
cued to form an emotional bond
with that person
and oxytocin by the way is the same
hormone that's released during sex and
childbirth fun fact
both moments when
from an evolutionary perspective we
benefit from feelings of closeness and
trust but also both moments you don't
want to be laughing
all right well
all right well i don't know
naomi and i have data on everything
we're going to save that for a different
podcast that's right right the bottom
line matt is giving birth having sex and
laughing with colleagues in zoo meetings
are actually have a lot in common
um we're building trust and no one's
wearing pants oh there you go
yes
no restraints
i'm laughing for the person who joins
the podcast on that one line naomi
what the heck am i listening to
so on this podcast we've spoken a lot
about the importance of engaging others
when we communicate how can humor help
us with that engagement and do you have
specific recommendations for when you
should use humor and when you shouldn't
yeah
um one of our favorite examples of this
was back in 2011 so
i remember watching president obama's
state of the union address
and about 40 minutes into a 60-minute
speech he makes this small joke
he's he's talking about the layers of
government bureaucracy
and uh and he illustrates it by making
this joke where the punchline is smoked
salmon
and it's sort of it's it's totally
not hilarious but in that context it was
really funny so the room erupts in
laughter you know and he pauses and he
moves on and i remember at the time
thinking oh that was you know that was
clever but not really thinking much more
than that well when npr
the next day surveyed its listeners
they asked which three words most stood
out from the entire state of the union
right so an hour long which three words
do people remember and so can you guess
matt the single word most frequently
mentioned
salmon salmon that is right what do i
win naomi what do i win you win an extra
book oh excellent
and a book
thank you
and what was fascinating about this is
this held true across political
affiliation as well
so you know humor
helps with engagement in part because
laughter when we laugh
our the reward center of our brains is
flooded with the neurotransmitter
dopamine so this engenders deeper focus
and better long-term retention so in
other words using humor not only can
make our content more engaging in the
moment but it also makes it more
memorable after the fact
or of course it could have been that uh
listeners were hungry
i didn't know i needed a degree in
neuroscience to talk to you guys about
humor we've got all this chemical stuff
going on but it sounds fascinating that
it helps not only in the moment but in
the long term as well
totally speaking of that long term
jennifer you've spent a good portion of
your career studying storytelling can
you share two or three best practices
for effective storytelling that also
apply to humor
you never really think about this but a
good story has a goal there's an aha at
the end of it
um and in a similar way when you use
humor or you try for a joke or you even
just laugh in one context
um oftentimes either implicitly or
or explicitly um you know really
effective humor there's a goal and the
goal might be to actually increase
status it could be to build bonds it
could be to diffuse tension in the room
but or you know it could even just be
the spark joy and have fun
but but what i found to be interesting
in the story work is
is the degree to which you dive into the
science of story you start to understand
that there's there's always an aha or a
goal of the storyteller when sharing the
story
um a second i think a second commonality
is that good stories they grab your
attention you know neurologically we're
wired to like see things or or or pay
attention to things that are
differentiated
and in a really similar way
you know humor something that
makes you laugh is oftentimes um
attention grabbing it you know defies
your expectation you think that the joke
teller is going in one direction and
then that direction is subverted um so i
think both have had those two
commonalities i would say um two other
things one
when you share stories in compelling
ways or even
you know just kind of co-create stories
with others
it often times becomes really engaging
and done well it's done authentically
and the real magic comes with when the
storyteller and the audience are so
connected
um you know story is kind of what lives
in between the storyteller as well as
the audience in a similar way um good
humor
humor that naomi and i define as like
lifting others up um or moving something
ahead is often also
you know in it's so engaging but it
really lives within between the space of
the joke teller
and the audience and last but not least
i would say that um
you know this idea of of
of creating um
uh
you know
and some sort of impact on the audience
good stories leave the audience
transformed right it's not just you know
the protagonist that's transformed in a
good story it's also the audience
and in a very similar way what we found
is that humor when done well and not
inappropriately we'll talk about that
later um really can transform the
audience
so there's an aha behind the haha is
what you're saying oh god you're so good
already
naomi can you provide specific guidance
on what we can do to create and
demonstrate humor
first is simply recognizing that humor
comes from truth
one of the most common misconceptions
among our clients and our students is
that
humor involves
inventing something from thin air
and when you think about it that way it
feels really hard
the reality is that it's more often
about simply noticing things that are
true for you so how you feel uh what you
uniquely think uh what makes you
unusually happy or unusually cranky
these sort of oddities or incongruities
in your life all of these things can be
incredible
fodder for humor it's about giving voice
to these observations so i grew up
watching seinfeld and if you think about
seinfeld
okay great did you watch seinfeld every
thursday night perfect okay so the show
about nothing right the the entire
premise of each show is one of these
observations right the low talker the
close talker uh shrinkage guys who paint
their faces for sporting events
and we often laugh at these things from
a recognition of truth i've done that
i've seen people do that i've heard
people talk about that
and so step one is just recognizing that
we're not creating things from thin air
we're just mining our lives for these
truths
so what kind of truths are we looking
for
the easiest one for people to access is
generally finding areas of contrast or
incongruities this would be my second
tip so these are things like how your
colleagues describe you versus your
family or
how you want to behave versus how you
actually behave
one of our students for example
he's getting an md
while he's doing his mba so he was
talking about how he needs to remember
the intricacies of krebs cycle for his
boards right so he's got all of these
these incredible memory tasks that he
has to do and yet for the life of him
every time he walks to the fridge he
can't remember what he come he came
there for
and see so he says you know i open the
fridge i can't remember and then
ultimately
i go to i get an ice cream snickers bar
right so this is but these are just
little tiny observations um and finally
specific so the more specific you can
get the better uh you know the fact that
uh the krebs cycle or you know it's not
just ice cream but it's a snickers bar
these specifics when you're mining your
life for for content for little
incongruities or oddities are often
where the comedy gold is
that's really insightful and very
specific i think all of us can do an
inventory of our lives and we can come
up with things that we can then try to
be funny about yeah
actually that that is an exercise that i
will challenge your listeners do to do
for a week this is what our students do
all quarter um every week they have to
write down 10 observations from their
life so you could do this i mean you
could even do one a day right one
observation of an incongruity something
odd something that you noticed and then
at the end of the week look at your
seven observations
and just try and turn one into comedy
wow ever the professor assigning
homework i love that homework i'm going
to start right away thank you for that
all right
what advice do you have for the many of
us who understand the power of humor and
levity but just don't think we're that
funny
well first it's it's really important to
recognize that the bar in business is
very low so it is so so low absolutely
so low
so even in the beginning of our class
our students report a real lack of
laughter in their lives
we have this direct quote from a student
on tuesday i did not laugh once
not once
their laugh journal was empty on tuesday
yeah exactly so the last part though
matt is the second part of this quote so
it goes on tuesday i did not laugh once
not once who knew a class about humor
could be so depressing
oh wow
day one
well you could only go up from there
exactly set a low bar just like the
humor bar in business
yeah so we build on that and we say like
it's not even about being funny it's
just being more generous with your
laughter
um dick costello who is the former ceo
of twitter he came to our class the
other day
and as he puts it he says you don't have
to be the quickest wit in the room the
easiest way to have more humor at work
is not to try to be funny instead just
look for moments to laugh ooh i like
that
yeah it's all good um what over the
course the class um our students really
experience this remarkable shift though
and so what began as a sobering
realization about humorless tuesdays
uh ends with students reporting
significantly more joy in their life and
this shift is is about so much more than
becoming funny or funnier they become
more generous with their laughter
right
i like how you you pivoted that from
being about
the myself worrying that i'm not funny
to something that i can do which is be
more generous and laugh more so it's
definitely something that gives me a
sense of agency and feels like something
very real that i can do
right another thing our students find
helpful is
recognizing that it's
it's not about being funny it's about
navigating the world in a slightly
different way
so in the class we talk about the
distinction between levity and humor
where levity is is a mindset so think of
that as sort of an inherent state of
receptiveness to
and active seeking of joy right how do
you go around the world are you going
are you walking around the world
expecting to be delighted or expecting
to be disappointed and so what we work
on more than anything is this mindset uh
you know noticing for opportunities
noticing opportunities for humor that
would otherwise pass us by
and it's it's our point of view in the
class that when you
walk around on the precipice of a smile
you will be surprised by how many things
you encounter that will push you over
the edge
that notion of of
being
receptive to
what's happening in humor
around you i think is fantastic i like
the idea of being the precipice of a
smile i would love to live my life uh in
that position
before we end uh we always ask the same
three questions of all of my guests and
i am really excited to hear how you all
answer these questions so jennifer i'm
going to start with you
if you were to capture the best
communication advice you have ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would it
be
i would say know your content
audience
and space in between i think i think
that's right tell me more about the
space in between we've talked a lot on
this podcast about knowing your audience
what do you mean by the space in between
well it's that it's that magical moment
when you you have a point that you want
to deliver or a story that you're
sharing
or a joke that you're you're you're
trying out
and there's the audience right and and
so um it's it's what happens in between
you know my story or my joke or my
content and and you
it's it's that in-between space that i
think is the most interesting and
important right and it's the most alive
too that's a that's exciting i'm i think
that's a really good title for a slide
and also really good advice
naomi what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe and i'm smiling as
i ask that question because you just
told us you're not a good cook
i would say
number one lean into your style so we
talk about this a lot in humor class if
you are
shy and understated lean into that if
you are naturally
character based charismatic if you use a
lot of hand motions whatever that is
lean into it and embrace it
we see folks trying to
embrace different humor styles that
don't feel natural to them or just
different communication styles
so whatever your natural style is lean
into it
the second i got from
a longtime mentor of mine chris ertel
who wrote the book moments of impact
and he talks about the last 20 minutes
before you do anything you should only
be focused on your state
so forget your content forget what
you're there to talk about forget you
know everything and just focus on your
state um getting in a good mindset
getting in a positive mindset
recognizing who's in the room what are
they probably feeling
um and then the third talk like a human
we talk about this in class that there's
so much
uh jargon especially in the way that we
communicate over email and if we can
strip that out of the way that we talk
especially as more of our communications
are moving
over email and over
you know different forms of electronic
communication if it's not something that
you would say in a casual conversation
then then don't say it in an email
wow
whatever recipe that those ingredients
go into is going to be fantastic people
will be amazing communicators
there's a lot of oregano yeah you gotta
you gotta put oregano that's true spice
spice it up
for both of you question number three
who is a communicator that you admire
and why
jennifer you go first i think leslie
blodgett you know she uh she is not only
a dear friend of ours she is the humor
ceo ambassador of our class
um was also the
ceo and founder of bare minerals but
whenever she comes in it's authentic
um and and she uses humor as oxygen she
she needs it she prioritizes it in every
single moment of her day
which includes
leading teams really in very inspired
ways
for me it's alison kluger so allison
teaches strategic communications
she was on the podcast
yeah so
allison is a is a dear friend and mentor
of mine and and she was a professor of
mine when i was a student at the gsb
what i admire about allison is the way
that she is able to balance such a broad
range of herself so being powerful and
approachable
uh you know kind but unafraid to
challenge um insightful and emotionally
attuned and she's always always caring
about the needs and well-being of the
people around her and that comes through
in how she communicates
um and just in her presence
that's a great tribute to allison and
everybody listening can can hear some of
that if you listen to the podcast we did
on reputation management
both of those communicators exemplify
some of the key concepts of what it
takes to be not just a good communicator
but a good human being
thank you both so much i have thoroughly
enjoyed learning from you and laughing
with you i am going to try my best to
put into practice the principles from
your book
having a an approach that is seeking joy
is just a wonderful way to live your
life thank you both best of luck with
the book and let's all have a good laugh
when we're all done thank you thank you
so much for having us matt
i have the biggest smile on my face i
still laugh every time i hear that
episode that line about the pants is
quite possibly the funniest thing that
has ever been said on think fast talk
smart and don't forget jennifer's
challenge write down one incongruity
every day and by the end of the week try
to turn one of those into comedy share
with us on our linkedin page
thanks for joining us for the think fast
talk smart summer learning series please
check out all three episodes in this
series think fast talk smart the podcast
is a production of stanford graduate
school of business this episode was
produced by podium podcast company jenny
luna and me matt abrahams
find more resources follow and join our
conversation on linkedin by searching
think fast talk smart and please
download and follow wherever you get
your podcasts and be sure to drop us a
review on spotify or apple podcasts
[Music]
you